tiger belly i am a 30 year old asian
american woman and i've never been in
love i've never been in a serious
relationship my whole life i have a
problem with finding a man i get asked
quite often but every single man that
has entered my life has been unpromising
a little backstory i grew up similar to
bobby where my dad was a rage monster i
know i have commitment issues due to my
childhood trauma but i also developed a
high standard for men in my life i
always grew up fearing i would meet a
man like my dad and turn out to be just
like my mom
so when i see this it's a red flag for
me do you guys think i should lower my
standards in men and double down in
hopes of falling in love or if i don't
lower my standard while i'll just be
single the rest of my life i think it's
a reframe so the issue is that she
likes she's a higher standard yeah it's
i miss the first part
[ __ ]
wait you get it one time now you gotta
go off
i think you should just reframe the way
you're saying lower your standards even
the way you use the word unpromising i
think that there's promise in everyone
you meet but if you go into the room
thinking that he's got to hit all the
boxes you're not really allowing
yourself for allowing you know a
relationship to ever you know flourish
from there because you're like well he's
not checking these boxes so you're not
being open
um
and that's really all i have to say
about that is that you you can't have
these like
no
you gotta no here's the thing babe it's
like no if if i were to just on paper on
paper you're disastrous
on paper
right
wait wait wait wait
on paper i'm disastrous yeah if somebody
oh really oh really okay so college
degrees
podcast
i paid for every meal based on my
standards basically oh yeah i'm not
[ __ ] michael phelps no even like the
height standard of like yeah before you
didn't meet
yeah but you shouldn't have why was that
even in your thing
that's so shallow that's what she might
do five four is not a thing exactly i'm
trying to say that i when i had coffee
with you i took that criterion book and
i was like [ __ ] this i like this guy
whatever amalgamation of red fat right
the red fat right here has a beautiful
girlfriend you know man she didn't have
a [ __ ] lipstick
she said
and he's got you on the height what i'm
saying is this
look i didn't do anything i'm just i'm
your friend
i can't move
lava
[ __ ] okay season
[Laughter]
what i'm saying to this lady is this all
right
don't listen to her look at sterling and
i okay we're we're we look like you know
it's an old joke handsome no we look
like a
garbage bag full of oatmeal that's what
our bodies are but oatmeal is healthy
for you yeah yeah yeah right oatmeal
we're just like globs right but we're
creative we're fun we have funny laughs
right and we we support each our lives
through art right and being creative
right so it's like you know you gotta
change what you think you want yeah
except except do not settle on his
character if his character is [ __ ]
that's the one thing you should never
settle on in terms of looks his job like
tiny little things here and there yeah
absolutely lower your standards because
you you'll meet so many i don't know
you're just opening up
yourself to people like bobby
who's an amazing
wonderful creature
challenge
talented creature yeah
let me ask you something yeah
when you look like that you know i mean
on the photo
back then
and you were probably struggling were
you struggling as an artist back then
yeah no money right
did you get girls then yeah
what a nice guy oh you're nice you seem
like you've always been confident yeah
nice guy yeah you're a confident i'm fun
yeah you're a fun guy you got to be fun
yeah yeah
i love this guy yeah
so any any other ones
a lot of them are honestly for
reservation dogs people just saying you
were awesome in it in episode two
seriously
i'm not kidding you're hit like
seriously my twitter is
full of it yeah
it's the first time i've had
friends same my age
texts what do you mean like they're
writing you about it well it's it's more
like
people my age are watching it